No. Yeah. I don't I don't want you to
debate if you don't want to.
No. No. No. I want to. I want to. I want
to. All right. Why though? I'm curious.
Um
I don't know. Just for the sake of it,
bro.
Nah, Mazin,
you got to watch this. Bro, how do you
do this? How do you still do this? like
because just Saturday night we got
another Muslim to convert to
Christianity and then the next day his
wife also converted to
Christianity that's why I still do this
and you should have heard him before he
made the decision he was very scared he
was afraid that his wife would leave him
that his community would abandon him or
that or he was afraid of losing his
community and really them unalivvening
him And uh the fear in his voice and him
being brought to tears, this grown man
being brought to tears, it moves me. It
brought me to tears as well. And it
showed it reminded me, it was just
another confirmation of why I do
this. People are waking up.
That's how you see it, bro.
Um I feel bad for the guy,
bro. Give me give me his uh give me his
Tik Tok.
some straight. Some straight. He's
already been set straight by the Lord
Jesus, man.
He's been set straight by the Lord
Jesus. So, uh that's that's that's what
that's what this is about, man. This
ain't about, you know, debating and
arguing for argument's sake or for
debate's sake. It's about reaching
people who are open. Man, I agree.
Debating debating just for debating is
wrong. Yeah.
Okay. So, let me talk to let me talk to
somebody else. Man, I did I miss you,
though. I'll tell you that.
Uh I miss you, but
like kind of kind of There we go. I'll
take that. All right. All right. Peace,
bro.
I'm out. I'm out of this, bro.
Peace. M in. Ladies and gents. All
right. We got somebody else on stage. N
G O M A. I don't know how to say your
name,
Jafar. Jafar, you you hear
me? All right, let's get some uh YouTube
guests going. Let's go. We got Choppin
here. Chopin, how you doing? Oh, hello.
Do you hear me? I can hear you, man.
You're a Muslim? Uh, yes. Alhamdulillah.
All right. So, what you think? Uh, by
the way, I'm sorry. I'm so sorry for
saying this. Uh, but can I ask an
off-topic question? No.
Okay, I will I'll ask you. Okay. Uh, so
you say Jesus did not teach uh Islam or
something? Well, my question is did
Jesus teach did he teach Christianity or
did he teach Islam? I believe he teach
Islam. Okay. And why do you believe
that? Uh because he taught theism.
That's true. He did teach monotheism,
but Christianity is monotheism. Judaism
is monotheism. There's other faith
monotheism, but I don't think the
doctrine of the trinity is what
representing monotheism.
Okay, that's that's fine. Um, I would I
would say that I don't think that the
doctrine of consists of monotheism
either.
Okay. So, you're going to talk about the
trinity or right now? I pointed at the
trinity. Oh, and I pointed out.
Can I talk about the trinity? I want you
to talk about what Jesus preached. Yeah.
Yes. And then uh you guys believe uh he
taught that he's God and he's the son of
God. He's uh that's what Jesus taught.
Yes. You believe that? That's what Jesus
taught. So yeah
and I want to tell you why he didn't
teach that. Okay. So but first we got to
know where are we getting this from? So
where do we go to uh see what Jesus
taught so that we can make this decision
so we can come to a conclusion. Okay. I
want
to Okay. So when you say Jesus said uh
claim to be God which is something I
don't believe by the way. Of course
you're not God.
Uh there's many vers uh there are many
verses where he says for example
uh the father is is the only true god or
the father is greater than I. Okay. Uh
let's deal with those two verses. Let's
deal with those two just for now. So
when he says he says that the father is
greater than I. He says that the only
true god is the father. So Jesus is
preaching that god is his father. Right?
Okay. So, he's not preaching Islam,
right?
Uh, you mean that we can't go, we can't
call Allah father.
Correct. Because Allah is not the
father, right? Hello. Can you hear me?
Testing, testing, testing, testing. Uh,
sorry, I lost connection a bit. Can you
hear me now? So, Oh, yeah. So, yeah.
Yes. Yes. Yeah. So, so when Jesus is
teaching that God is his father, is he
preaching Islam?
If Jesus is teaching that he's not God
and he's a servant of God, then he's
basically not teaching what Christians
believe today. Okay. Is he teaching
Islam when he says that God is his
father?
Uh we don't have a problem in people.
people back then used to call uh God by
different names for example. Okay. So
when Jesus is preaching that God is his
father, is he preaching
Islam? Okay. By the definition of the
father, he's teaching that he's not God.
Okay, I would say yes.
So the answer is yes. When Jesus is
preaching that God is his father, he's
basically saying he has a
Islam. Just
be a yes. Okay. So can you show me in
Islam, can you show me the Quran or a
hadith that says that Jesus is Allah's
son?
No, it doesn't exist in that verse or
hadith. But I thought that he's
preaching Islam when he says that. Yeah,
by saying uh he is a servant of God. No,
no, father is basically God. I'm going
to be I'm going to be very clear. Yeah,
I know what you're saying. Okay. So,
please don't I know what you're saying.
All right. So, then let's let's let's
not play. Okay. We're not talking about
a servant master. We're very being very
very clear and specific. If he is
teaching Christianity, then he's saying
he's God. Just to be clear, hold on,
hold on. You just said that it's nowhere
in your Quran nor is it in your hadith
that Jesus is Allah's son. So is that is
is that Islamic that Jesus is Allah's
son? No. I don't believe that. Very
good. So if Jesus is preaching that God
is his father, is he preaching Islam?
uh by the definition that he has a god.
Yes, I did say yes to the question
because you believe that God is the
father is the god is god basically. Take
care of yourself.
Um you're up next. Um hello. Hello.
Um so what
question do you have exactly? Did Jesus
preach Christianity or did he preach
Islam? Islam.
All right. How do you know that? Um, so
from the Islamic perspective, we have to
take it step by step. So I'm a Muslim.
So it says in in um the Quran that um
Jesus is a prophet. Then we can now go
to the historical facts. Then the
historical facts we have to look about
um we have to look for what historical
facts are about Jesus which is from the
um Bible. But obviously, you know, the
Bible is um corrupted. But let's um so
the historical facts are corrupted. No.
Um basically what I'm trying to say that
um um Muslims we we use um the Quran to
judge the Bible. So like that's how we
Is it okay if I use the Bible to judge
the Quran?
Um sure. But the Bible you're using is
corrupted. Yeah. And the Quran you're
using is corrupted. Yeah. Um, that's
what you think, right? Yeah. Yeah. So,
um,
where do we go from here? That's um
that's what I'm trying to say. Um, so
when we check the Bible, um, we see some
similarities with the Quran. When he
talks about the father and when he talks
about who? The father. And you're saying
that when he talks about the father,
there's a similarity with the Quran.
Yeah. Like those verses that you guys
were talking about just um a minute ago.
Just to be clear. Yeah. When Jesus is
talking about the father,
you're saying that there's similarities
with how Jesus talks about the father in
the Quran. No, no, no, no. I'm saying
that when Jesus talks about the father,
he's trying to say that the father is
bigger than him. So like the concept,
not like the actual words. You get me?
Okay. So when Jesus refers to God as his
father Yeah. and is teaching that the
only true God is the father. Yeah. Is
that the message of Islam? Yeah. Cuz um
if you think about it um you said yeah.
Yeah. Let me explain actually um when
you think about um the meaning of Islam
before the Quran.
The only thing I want my brother I'm
trying to like explain like I'm not
trying to bring a verse to you like Oh,
you're not trying to bring a verse. Of
of course you guys aren't trying to
bring verses. Whenever you guys say
something, you're not trying to bring
verses to me. Why is that? When you look
at the um at Islam before the Quran, we
normally say that Islam is when you
believe in one God. So So anybody who
believes in one God is a is is part of
the religion of Islam. Yeah. So I can
believe in I can believe in one god.
Yeah. I can believe in one god and my
one god is an idol that I have. I'm part
of Islam. One god that um that you that
is only to be woripped. And um yeah I
say that the idol that I have is the
only one worthy of worship. Um okay then
let me clarify. Not an idol. Wait not an
idol. Why? Why not an idol? It's one god
that I believe. Yeah. An idol um god
cannot be seen. So you can't really
create an idol of So but it doesn't
matter. You're you refuting or having an
issue with my theological view does not
take me out of the standard that you set
for me to qualify to be within Islam.
You said all I need to do to be in Islam
is believe in one God. So I believe in
one God. It's just an idol that I have.
Not you. The hypothetical you in in that
like what Islam not you. We talking
about like a hypothetical situation,
right?
Yeah. Hypothetically, I believe in I
believe in one God who is an idol. It's
an idol that I have in my in my closet.
Am I in I'm in Islam, right?
Hypothetically, if you were at that time
and you believed in one God um and you
woripped worshiped him. Yeah. Worship
this one
idol. Be be clear. Let's say
hypothetically worship and worship. We
don't even have to use hypothetically.
We could use people like worshippers of
Bald for example. They they believed in
Bal. They believed that he's the only
one worthy of worship. Okay. B
worshippers. They worshiped Baal as the
only god.
Yep. They worship they worshiped Baal as
the only god. Were they within the
religion of Islam?
You see the thing is that you're taking
it out of context. I'm taking it out of
context. What am I taking out of
context? Give me a second. Give me a
second. What you said? What I said is
that believing in one God is part of the
doctrines that qualify you to be a
Muslim to be That's not what you said.
That's what you're saying now. That's
not what you said before. Okay. Just try
and that's what I'm I'm trying to
explain what I meant cuz you you're
taking me a bit out of context. Me
believing in one God alone isn't what
qualifies me to be a Muslim. There are a
lot of other qualifications within the
Quran that
combined qualify me to be a Muslim. Very
good. So I can believe in one God but
still not be a Muslim, still not be
within the religion of Islam. Correct?
Yes. Yes. Very good. So if I believe in
one
God, who I say the one God is matters,
doesn't it? Yes. Okay. So when Jesus is
saying that the one God is his father,
does that match with Islam?
No. Very good. So when Jesus is saying
that the one God is his father, which
doesn't match with Islam, then that
means that Jesus is not preaching Islam.
Correct?
Okay. So is that correct? Calm down.
It's not It's not a yes or no question.
It is a yes or no. That's why I'm
telling you it's not a yes or no. Let me
explain why. Explain why it's not yes or
no. I your grace I I beg 30 seconds to
explain why it's not a yes or no. Okay.
You know what? I'll give you 30 seconds
to explain why it's not a yes or no. And
if I'm not satisfied, I'm going to
demand a yes or no to my simple yes or
no question. All right. Go ahead. 30
seconds. All right. That's fine. Because
of you're taking you're taking the
context of the the um verse that you're
quoting directly.
What I'm saying is that when they when
he called him the father, he didn't mean
it as per his direct father, the context
in which he meant it or the context in
which I'm I'm personally interpreting it
and a lot of Muslims personally
interpret it is that he meant it as a
higher deity that control like when
Muslim call theelves slaves, they don't
they don't genuinely mean that God is
the slave master. Do you get what I'm
saying? It's in that context, not in the
direct English context of what you're
saying. All
right, that's 30 seconds. So, from what
I heard is that well, um, you know,
Jesus didn't mean that he's he's God's
literal son. And so, basically, you're
saying that Allah that Jesus is Allah's
son, just not literally. Is that right?
What I'm saying is that Jesus is a slave
of Allah. That's not what I asked you. I
didn't ask I didn't ask about I didn't
ask about a slave. I'll ask it again.
You're trying to push me into a corner.
No, you got yourself into a corner when
you said you got yourself Let me show
you. Let me show you where you went
wrong. All right. All right. Where you
where you where you put yourself into
the God logic trap is when you said that
when Jesus preaches about this the
father that there's similarities when he
preaches about the father with the
Quran. Yeah. That's where the snap you
snapped your ankle in the trap. Jesus
Jes Jesus didn't preach about the father
in the Quran. So we need to understand
but you didn't quote the Quran. You
quoted the Bible. Yes. And he said in in
the Bible the hold brother Jesus. Let me
finish this thought. Okay. So, so when
you quote the Bible and refer to parts
where Jesus preaches about his father
being his God and being the one God he
worships, you then are now stuck with
Jesus's theology that God is his father.
Now, you say, "Well, he doesn't mean it
literally." Okay, let me give this to
you that he doesn't mean it literally
is. So you're affirming that Islamically
within Islam, Jesus is the son of Allah
figuratively. Correct?
No. Very good. Because we are quoting a
verse from the Bible. So we cannot we
cannot then take it to Islam because we
need to put
so to be clear to be clear Allah is not
a father to anyone whether it's
figuratively literally metaphorically or
any way correct in no sense Allah is a
father
correct Islamic a sense yes he is in the
sense of how a father a father takes
care of his children do you get what I'm
saying Do mothers take care of their
children? A father is the head. A father
do mothers do mothers take care of their
children that sense. Yes. Do mothers
take care of their children? What do
mothers take care of their children?
Yes. Is Allah a mother in that sense?
In that sense, yes. In the sense of the
way that you are putting it. Yes.
519 on the hour and 15 minute
mark. Allah is a mother in some
sense.
Okay. Got an
hour
13. Let's go. Zero
zero. All right. Okay.
Okay.
Um. All right. So, yeah. So Allah is a
father in some sense and Allah is a
mother in some sense that he takes care
of his uh that a mother takes care of
her children and so Allah is a mother to
us and that he takes care of us. Yeah.
So on and so forth. Okay.
Got you. Can you show me where the Quran
says anything like this that he's a
father in the sense that he takes care
of us or that he's a mother that he
takes care of us?
It doesn't say it exactly in the words
that you're putting it in. Got it. But I
can I I can give it to you in a general
sense. Can I can I show you something
that the Quran says, okay, that you're
that you're doing that it tells you not
to do. All right.
In chapter 7, verse 180, I'm going put
on the screen for you, too. All
right. This is what it says here, bro.
To the left. Chapter 7 verse 180. It
says, "And to Allah belong the best
names. So invoke him by them and leave
those who practice deviation concerning
his names. They will be recompensed for
what they have been
doing." So this says that you are not
allowed to deviate from the names that
Allah already has.
Okay? You cannot call him by the by
anything that he has not referred to
himself
as yet you are referring to Allah as a
father and a mother in some sense.
Okay. So where where the issue is here
is that personally I'm going to tell you
that I did not know this verse off hand.
I don't know I have not memorized the
Quran. It's okay. Do you understand what
I'm saying? So I was answering your
question in the sense of the
intellectual meaning of what you're
asking me. Yeah. In that sense but I I
personally did not know I have wronged
or committed a sin. But in terms of what
we are intellectually discussing it does
not fall out of the category of what I
like I I like that. I actually like what
you just said. Intellectually you're
saying that you can make these anal
analogical connections with Allah with
these meanings and these characteristics
but Islamically you can't right
Islamically as we saw Quranically you're
not allowed to do that right and so I
appreciate one your humility and being
honest with being able to recognize that
I I appreciate that.
So then I ask I have to ask again.
Okay,
Jesus referring to God as his father,
whether it's metaphorically or not,
okay, from from the Islamic
paradigm, that's wrong to do, right?
Because father is not one of his names.
Okay?
So, if Jesus is calling God his father,
coronically, he's not preaching Islam.
Would we agree?
Oh, I agree with you there. It's
awesome. So, since Jesus is not
preaching Islam and Jesus is our beloved
Messiah, the beloved prophet of God, the
redeemer of mankind and savior of the
world, why then are you following Islam
when Jesus did not preach Islam?
What version of the Bible did you get
this from? Exactly. this verse that
you're quoting to me
uh about Jesus calling God his father.
Yeah. Any any any version of the Bible
doesn't matter what translation any of
them. Do you want some according
according to the Quran
the version of the Bible that we have
today has been corrupted. Where does the
Quran say that?
Okay, let me just give it. Give me a
minute. Let me look for it cuz I don't
know. is officially.
Oh, sorry. Sorry. Give me a minute. It's
okay. Figure time. Um, as you're looking
for that, I'll just read some super
chats. Is that all right? Yeah, that's
fine. That's fine. It'll give you it'll
give you some time because there's a
lot. So, let me let me just go ahead and
get through this. Um, so we got uh
Undercover Pro says, "Gl's question.
Where does the Quran say that the Torah
was given to Moses? Islamic contents
response." Bro, come
on. Interpretation. Trust me,
bro. Bree says, "We don't debate to be
right and stroke our egos. We debate
twin souls which glorifies our Lord
Jesus Christ the righteous. That's
right. McDonald's Muta says Muhammad is
mentioned several times in the Bible.
Matthew 7:15-20, Luke 6:26, Jeremiah
27:14-15. Uh reach these kids God
logic. John John says, "Pray for Anas
Islamic apex. He had a visual reaction
on need God's heated Muslim video six
days ago and his sin and salvation was
brought up. Wow. All right. Well, let's
pray that anas Islamic apex comes to
repentance. Okay, I'm ready. All right.
So, in surah bakar um chapter 2 verse
79.
Yeah.
Did you see me lip the verse that you
were about to Yeah. Yeah. I saw you. I
saw you.
That let you know I'm I'm very familiar
with these arguments, you know. Yeah. I
can see it's something you do for a
living.
Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. All right. So, 279 it says, "Woe
to those who write the book with their
own hands, claiming it's from God,
seeking a small price. W to those for
what their hands have written and W to
those for what they earn.
Right. 75 75 not 79. Sorry, my bad.
Okay. So 79 talks about how there's a
party of them who distort the book after
or distort after hearing,
right? And understanding it.
Yeah. Yeah. Okay. So, just to be
clear, does 75 tell you how they
distort?
No, they didn't. Nope. I would think
actually. Okay. It would it implies a
verbal distortion because it talks about
how they distort after they heard it.
Okay. Right. So, they heard the words
and then distorted the words.
Understood it. So they are lying about
what they heard or misinterpreting what
they heard. Okay. So that's that's how
you see it exactly that we're trying to
see. Yep. Okay. So I have a question for
you. How exactly was the Bible compiled
and written?
Well, it's written by the disciples of
Jesus or people who knew the disciples
and the prophets and
um these these these letters or these
epistles from the apostles or these
gospel accounts were spread around or
sent and shared among different churches
around around the area to different
lands, different cities and stuff like
that. Some people might have a copy of
go of of Mark's gospel but not of
Luke's. And then they'll run into
someone who has Luke's gospel and say,
"Oh, we need this, too." And vice versa.
Right? So, so that's how the gospel
accounts got in circulation. We have the
followers of the disciples, which we
call the church fathers, that also
continued the tradition of the gospel
and their teachings and continued to
pass this on throughout the church.
Okay. So, the only people that
documented the Bible were the apostles
like the disciples. Yes. Those were the
only people that Yep. So, you have the
apostles or you have the people who were
companions of the apostles, right? So
like for example Luke himself, Luke was
not a direct disciple of Jesus but he
did accompany uh Paul and Barnabas and
others in spreading the message and
going around and wrote a historical
account. So he wrote the book of acts
that was the account of the church
exploding after Jesus ascended and the
works of the apostles. Yeah. He also
wrote you know the gospel after
interviewing the eyewitnesses.
So the women and the other the other
apostles he uh you know interviewed them
and wrote down an ordered account. So
the primary form of collection of this
information before writing it down was
hearing.
Yes. Yes. Yes. They went around
spreading the message and Yeah. So, it
could have been
distorted from the point that they heard
it because you said that from what the
Quran says is when they heard it before
it was distorted. Well, well, no. So,
what you're talking about in 275 is a
different time, right? Like hearing it
and distorting it. They can do that, but
that has nothing to do with the writing
of the text. The written text is still
intact. You get what I'm saying? So if
somebody is coming around and by the way
there were people that did this. There
were people that went around like for
example the guy a guy named Marcian he
went around um and distorted the gospel
and meaning he was lying about the
gospel. And matter of fact he I think
took uh if I'm not mistaken Luke's
gospel only. I think he rejected
Matthews and the others but I think he
only held to Luke's gospel account and
then also removed tried to remove stuff
that he didn't like that didn't go with
his view and uh he got called out from
it because why one we have the oral
tradition from the apostles and the
church fathers the bishops and then two
we also have the manuscript tradition
that exposes him. So okay we we we know
if somebody tries to tries something
it's it's impossible to corrupt to in
totality
it's impossible is a very strong word
impossible impossible okay so so what
you would have to do to corrupt the
gospel the New Testament is you would
have to gather every sing all the
thousands of manuscripts that we have
you have to gather them all um from the
different countries and cities and
places that they're in that they're held
in. Um, get past the security behind
them and the people holding them. Sneak
and steal all these manuscripts, rewrite
all of them, like change go in them and
change what you want to change. Yeah.
And then put them back in the same
places where you found them, the same
way that you found them, so that and so
that no one notices. That's what you'll
have to do. It's impossible.
Okay. But then what confirmation that
those who listened and recorded it, the
first people who listened and recorded
it did not distort it before writing.
Well, we it's consistent, bro. It's a
cons. We have a consistent oral
tradition from the church fathers and
who learned directly under the apostles
continuing the oral tradition. Also, we
have the manuscript tradition that's
that's consistent. You know, it's it's
not we don't have any reason to believe
it's it's other than what we have.
There's no evidence suggesting
otherwise. Okay. What what was the name
of the apostle's friend that was also
part of the documentation process that
you mentioned? Luke. Yeah. Luke. Okay.
Let's say Luke heard the word now and
then he wrote differently from what he
heard. How exactly would that be
confirmed? Because you have other people
who heard and have other have gospel
accounts and and know the gospel, know
the events and what happened. So they
would be able to call Luke out for
misrepresenting or lying.
Okay.
So now I understand what where you're
coming from. But you have taken a big
assumption in your entire thought
process is that the verse that I quoted
was distorted from hearing and not from
writing. Well, I don't I don't think
it's that big of an assumption. Let me
tell you why. Yeah. Because whenever you
you see the Quran talk about distortion
of the scripture, okay, it's always
whenever it talks about explicitly, it's
always with their tongues. Always.
You'll never see the Quran say that they
distort with their with the writing.
You'll never see that. But there are
also places where they didn't mention
explicitly whether it was with the
tongue or with their writing. Well, what
I would what I would say is is that
there's there's never I I I would give
you this. If if there's verses mentioned
about
distortion, it it it's in those
contexts, it's never it's never
textually. It's always misinterpretation
and lying about what it says. It's never
about writing ever from their context.
Okay. Um so that's just from the theme
of the Quran and how it uses it in their
context. That's why what I'm saying is
it's not a it's not a assumption but
based on what the Quran says as a whole
on the subject I know it's not textual
corruption. Yeah. But what you what
you're saying is that in other places
where it has been mentioned and he has
been explicitly stated that it was the
tongue sorry it was from hearing and
distortion after hearing but this verse
that I brought to you specifically
doesn't speak about whether it's through
hearing or through writing. Well, it
says it is it is still an assumption at
the end that it is through hearing
regardless of whether the trend. Well,
this is what the verse says, brother
spoken about. The ver the verse says a
party of them used to hear the words of
Allah and then
distort. They used to hear the words of
Allah and then distort after they
understood it. Right? So,
um, you hear words. Yeah. And then you
distort what you heard. That's you lying
about what you heard. Now, I I can grant
and be honest, it doesn't it it doesn't
necessarily tell us how they distort,
right? You would have to glean that from
the rest of the Quran, right? And and
that's what I'm doing. I'm using the cor
the rest of the Quran to come to the
conclusion about this verse as well as
as well as the implications that this
verse shows themselves. If they're
hearing the words and then distorting
what they heard, that's verbal
corruption, not textual.
I get what you're saying. But you can
also give me the fact that since the
distortion is not stated, we cannot 100%
say that it was through um audio that it
was distorted with this verse alone.
Sure. With this verse alone, I would I
would not say 100% you can conclude that
it's not textural. All right. All right.
Okay. I think I don't know. Is there
anything else for us to argue about?
Yes. I want you I want to I want to show
you the opposite. I'm going to show you
that the Quran explicitly says that the
the scriptures that's with the Jews and
Christians that it's it confirms them.
Okay, we use chapter two. We'll stay in
chapter two. Like so when I tell you
context and theme, go ahead. Sorry,
which verse did you did you say? I
didn't I didn't say a verse yet, but I
just said we're going to stay in chapter
two. I'm going to show you in chapter
two alone. I can go elsewhere, but just
in chapter two, it continues over and
over and over again saying that the
Quran confirms what they have, that what
they have is true. Okay? So, the first
one I'm going to show you is in chapter
2, verse 41.
Verse
41. Mhm. So that is the verse that says,
"And believe in what I revealed,
confirming what is with you, and do not
be the first to deny it and do not
exchange my revelations for a small
price and be conscious of me."
Yep. So the Quran there says, "Belie,
believe in the Quran that he sent down
the book, right, which is the Quran.
Believe in what we have sent down
confirming what is with you." So they
have the scriptures with them. So the
Quran is confirming that what they have
is true. They might also have meant it
in the context of where you see the
Quran confirms the scriptures that you
have are the places that it hasn't been
corrupted. Nope. The Quran doesn't say
that. The Quran nowhere says that the
scriptures have been corrupted. Nowhere
does it say that it's that it only
confirms part of the scriptures. It
always is in hold confirming what is
with you. It never calls. Doesn't say
that explicitly in this verse though. It
does. It says confirming what is with
you. Confirming what is with you doesn't
mean confirming the whole of what is
with you or part of what is with you.
Just says confirming what is with you.
Yeah. Literally, brother, if I'm
confirming what is with you, that's not
part of what's with you. That's not some
of what's with you. What you have is
true. That's what I I blatantly said
that, you
know. So, let me actually show you that
the Quran doesn't the Quran actually
hates this idea of believing in part of
his scriptures. Okay? Still, still in
chapter 2, go to verse 85, for example.
Okay?
So, read that really quick. Verse what?
Verse 85. 85.
Okay. But here you are killing your own
and expelling a group of your own from
their homes, conspiring against them in
wrongdoing and hostility. And if they
come to you as captives, you ransom
them, although it was forbidden to you.
It is it that you believe in parts of
the scripture and disbelieve in parts?
What is the role for those among you who
do that but humiliation in this life and
on the day of resurrection they will be
assigned the most severe torment. God is
not unaware of what you do.
Okay. So Allah says now in context it's
talking about Jews who are obeying part
of their scripture but disobeying the
other parts. Right? And he says, "Do you
believe in part of the scripture and
disbelieve in the other parts? If you do
that, you're going to be disgraced in
this life and you'll have a severe
punishment in the hereafter. Allah knows
what you're doing. He ain't he ain't
he's not blind." Okay? Right? So Allah
has this principle. He hates people who
pick and choose part of his scripture to
believe in and reject other parts of his
scriptures. Of course.
So it then with that understanding that
principle when Allah says he confirms
what is with you. It would be silly for
Allah who hates people who pick and
choose to be saying that he's conf he's
picking and choosing what he's
confirming. Okay. He say he's confirming
what's with you. I hear what you say. I
hear what you say. But in in this in the
context of the verse that you have
brought to me, it means that you
shouldn't pick and choose the part of
the
scriptures from the unadultered
scriptures. Like Allah here is
definitely talking about his scriptures
that are unadultered. He's definitely
not talking about scriptures that have
been changed. Is that not true? He's he
doesn't say anything. He doesn't believe
his scriptures been changed at all.
There is no there is no concept of
adulterated scriptures in the Quran.
There's no concept of that.
Did we the the verse that we just spoke
about verse 25 just talked about how
people can distort the scriptures after
hearing it. So not textually.
That's that's what we came to agree to
disagree on. No, we didn't agree to
Wait, you're saying that that's textual
corruption? It could be textual
corruption based on because of the that
verse in specific does not mention
whether the distort distortion was
textually or I thought we made progress.
Okay. So what I need you to do then
since it looks like you're holding on to
this and this is a stumbling block. What
I need you to do is I need you to show
me in the Quran where it talks about
textual corruption. That's what I need.
Unfortunately, I can't do that because I
don't know every verse in the Quran.
Unless you would wait for me to search
for it. I don't know. I actually don't
know. It doesn't exist. That's that's
the point of me asking you that it
doesn't exist. Okay. Okay. So, what I'm
saying is the I'm highlighting the
point. All right. Quran is consistent
when it talks about distortion, about
misinterpretation, and them lying about
what the verses say, not going in there
and actually changing the Torah. The
Quran and and then it wouldn't make
sense. The Quran says that it's
confirming what's with them, but in but
then says that what is what is with them
is corrupted. That would mean that
Allah's confirming corrupted scripture.
That's silly. Okay. So, let me let me
ask you a question. Every single version
of the Bible that is available, is it
the same?
Yes, it has the same themes, the same
messages. You know what I'm saying? I'm
not talking about the same themes and
the same messages. I'm talking about the
words themselves. Are
they Bible? Yeah. No. No. They're not
word for word exactly the same. You have
textual variances. We're talking about
ancient manuscripts here. There's
there's textual variances, but none of
them change the message or the theme or
the context.
The thing is if there are textual
variances, it can easily be corrupted.
You sure? Yes. Are you sure that's your
view? You know when you know when you
you share the
same you know when you share the same
copy of the same book, nobody can
dispute what the copy of the book is.
But if you share the a particular book
that has been written in different ways,
but they mean the same thing. I'm not
disputing what you're saying. They mean
the same thing. But it has been written
in different ways. You can dispute
different parts of the book because you
can say okay it was written here this
way in here was written this way in here
but the context does not mean the same
thing. All right. So then that would
mean then that the Quran is corrupted
then right because it has these textual
variances
where where which textual variances do
you know about the Quran? Oh brother I'm
glad you
asked. You've come to the right place my
friend. I am your friendly neighborhood
apologist. This is going to be chapter
37 verse12. I'm going to show you the
hops Quran. The hops Quran. And then I'm
going show you. Okay. But I have one
question. Are we speaking about the
Arabic? Yes. Or the translation. Arabic.
Arabic.
Um, why does it where does the bottom
part I hate that it does this? Hold
on. Maybe I just got to pull it over a
little bit. Do
that.
Oops. What just happened?
Okay, this ain't working. I'm tripping
right now. All
right, let's do this.
All right, there we go. All right. Can
you see the screen? Okay. Okay. Do you
read Arabic at all? Yeah, I do. Oh,
that's perfect. Okay. I don't understand
it, but I can read it like Yeah. Okay,
that's good. All
right. So, this is uh what I'm going to
show you. I'm going to show you the
huffs. This is the house Quran. This is
Arabic. Okay. Are you able to I don't
know if it's big enough. Are you able to
see this?
Yeah. Okay. What What does it say? Okay.
This says
Correct. Do you know what that means?
No, I don't. It means you wondered while
they mocked. Okay. So, this is Allah
speaking to Muhammad about when he was
reciting the revelation to the
disbelievers. And he says to Muhammad,
you wonder why they mocked. I The word
that we're specifically looking at is a
ta. It's you wonder. The ta makes it
you. The subject is you. Allah speaking
to the person about the person. All
right. Okay.
So, now when we scroll down, we're going
to go to
the version of the Quran. Okay. What are
the what's what's the h and like what
does it mean exactly? So, hs is a person
who it's it's bas it's a recitation of
the Quran that is under the authority of
assum. So hops is a person who has a
particular tradition of reciting the
Quran, right? And so all of these these
people are these names. That's what they
are. So you got Hoffs, you got Koon, you
got Wars, right? Um Okay. Okay. Okay.
There basically different methods of
reciting the Quran.
Sure. But um but um not necessarily not
just reciting these are like it's the
text. So these are different different
readings of the Quran. Okay. So hops is
the most popular one that's this hops
was standardized in 1924 in in uh Cairo
Egypt. Okay. That became like the
standardized one that most Muslims use
around the world. But yeah, these other
ones people use like uh like the worsh
right here. This wash Quran. Yeah. This
is used in North Africa. That's like the
stand used in North Africa. Right. Okay.
So the H says you
wonder you wonder why they right now
Khalif in his Quran. Okay. It says too.
Okay. Right. Which switches the subject
switches from you to I. He says I wonder
why they mocked.
Okay. So in in hs Allah says talking to
Muhammad you wonder why they mock. In
Khalif Allah says I wonder why they
mock. Okay. So you see the textual
variant there. Okay. Okay. I agree with
you on that. I do see the textual
variant.
So now some people try to reconcile
this. They say, "Oh, well, you know,
yeah, both, you know, Allah and Muhammad
wondered, you know, but Allah wondered
in a in a way that befits him." Ah,
that's fine. However you interpret that,
that's fine. That's not my argument. My
argument is about the the variances. The
the variant here changes the it changes
the meaning and the context from
Muhammad being the one wondering versus
Allah being the one wondering, you know.
Okay. So with that being said, if we're
going with that with like what you said,
if there's textual
variances, then this would show that,
you know, the text can be disputed or
and that would entail corruption, then
this would mean that the Quran may it
may be corrupted. We can we can probably
argue that.
You get what I'm saying? Yeah. I I do
get what you're saying. I do get what
you're saying.
Now, let me show you let me tell you why
this isn't a problem for Christians. For
Christians, okay, we don't hold that the
Bible is like the exact speech of God
himself. Like, we don't it's word for
word, letter for letter what God exactly
said. Only in the parts where God
speaks. Like if it's thus says the Lord
and then they're quoting God, those are
God. That's God's. Okay. So what you're
trying to explain to me is that
everywhere except for when God speaks
himself, the the scriptures are there's
leeway for the scriptures to be
different. Is that what you're trying to
say? What what I'm saying is is that the
way that God transmitted the scriptures
in Christianity, he used man to do it.
And so there can like a a man can can
make a mist a grammar mistake or um um
you know forget a line or or copy a line
twice you know um like these things can
happen within the text. However, God
preserves the message and the meaning of
you know of of the religion. So even
though there's textual variances because
man is writing these things. God used
man to write his scripture and his
message. God preserves the meaning.
Okay. Um, yeah. But in Islam, it's
different. In Islam, you guys believe
that every word of the Quran is the word
of Allah. Like word for word. Allah is
the one speaking this. You know, no one
else. It's not man's dealing. It's it's
Allah. Right? So, the problem comes
where it's okay. So, which one did Allah
say then? Did Allah say you wondered why
you mocked why while you mocked or why
they mocked Muhammad? Or did he say, "I
wondered why they mocked." Both of them
Islamically, they can't both be true
because like which one did Allah
actually say? Which one is in the
preserved tablet from eternity, you
know?
Okay. Okay. So, yeah. Go ahead. So, what
I what I think I'm going to go and need
to do is to go and research more the
difference between all these wors and
and understand why there are differences
cuz I don't understand that right now.
So, I can't argue on it.
Fair enough. So, I'll have to go back to
on that, but fair enough. Thank you for
pointing that out. I'll go and do more
research. Yeah, bro. Look, man. We We've
got If you want, man. Um just like just
helping in research. We've we have
lives. I have lives on my YouTube
channel dedicated to this subject and
showing examples, quoting Islam, not
Christian or atheist sources. We're
quoting Islamic scholars, Islamic
Tapsier commentaries, you know, that are
talking about these things and
acknowledging these things. And, you
know, I I like we we show we present and
give you information. We show you the
slides. We show you what scholars are
saying even today. So, we I have lives
on these on this subject um dedicated to
this stuff. So, you want to, you know,
just help with your research. I think uh
my my my lives on this would help you
like it gives you where where to go if
you want to look at some some of this
stuff. All right. All right. I'll I'll
give it a go. I'll give it a go for
sure. Well, this this was a respectful
conversation, man. I I want you to come
back, man, because I want to see what
you find. If you have other objections
or whatever, yeah, come back. Yeah,
you're you're more than welcome. All
right. No problem. All right. Take care
of yourself, man. Thanks for coming.
Okay.